[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on ne peut plus rire de rien
paraît-il mais y at il eu à temps où
l'on pouvait rire de tout la satire
consiste à s'attaquer à quelque chose ou
à quelqu'un en s'en moquant
c'est donc étroitement liée à la liberté
d'expression
je reçois aujourd'hui cédric passard et
de miramont pour leur livre sur la
satire et la liberté d'expression il est
intitulé de quoi se moque t'on il vient
de paraître aux éditions du cnrs
mais commençons d'abord par notre époque
qu'est ce qui la caractérise
voici votre réponse en images c'est une
de charlie hebdo alors je vous laisse là
commenté cédric passard oui en fait on a
choisi cette scène une parce qu'elle
révèle bien en fait les polémiques qui
est qu'ils ont créée par rapport à la
satire depuis une bonne dizaine d'années
c'est à dire que dans les années 80 on
avait évidemment des forme de satire qui
était qui étaient présentes notamment
sur un registre télévisuel mais c'est un
peu dépolitiser on pense au bébête show
on pense à ce qui existait dans les
grands formats médiatique et charlie
hebdo qui existe depuis assez longtemps
c'est vrai que symbolise bien là toutes
les détentions les crispations qui n'ont
pu ressurgir ces dernières années et
donc c'est tunnel fait référence à un
moment où justement on avait enjoint
charlie hebdo à être un journal
responsable et donc là la réponse de
charlie hebdo c'était de dire voilà on
va vous montrer ce que c'est qu'un
journal responsables les avait fait une
une blanche en fait comme si finalement
ajourné un responsable si les six
satirique saint jouin qu'on ne pouvait
rien dire et cet autre une qui était
justement la version de la satire en
tant que tel qui joue avec le feu au
fond vous ayez de miramont ccao fawcett
c'est une aurait aurait pu être la
couverture de votre livre on
al'impression elle donne une parfaite
définition
alors ils disent l'invention de l'humour
j'ai l'impression que c'est plutôt
l'invention de la satire justement
l'humour cet anglais oui oui
effectivement puisque là si on définit
l'humour par le fait de se moquer de
soi-même là en fait on est dans un cadre
tout à fait différent puisque en fait le
contexte qu'il faut peut-être rappeler
très vieille brièvement c'était en 2012
c'était l'époque où un une sorte de film
était sorti en vidéo
s'appelle une l'innocence des musulmans
et avait suscité quelques manifestations
et même quelques émeutes et donc charlie
hebdo à cette époque-là avait relayé
l'information publiée aussi quelques
caricatures en 2012 et le ministre des
affaires étrangères de l'époque qui
était dans mon souvenir laurent fabius
avait effectivement en juin à charlie
hebdo à de faire de faire preuve de
responsabilité
effectivement il ya cette métaphore de
l'huile et du feu donc ses 10 rebonds
mais il ne faut pas jeter d'huile sur le
feu ils semblent en fait
l'interprétation qu'on peut donner de
cette caricature c'est que la satire par
essence est presque de façon originale
consiste évidemment à jeter d'huile sur
le feu si on pouvait pas le faire y
aurait pas de ça tire et ça renvoie
effectivement une sorte d'innocence
fresque d'étape premier de ce qui serait
le geste satire et qui consiste
évidemment à se moquer et à s'affranchir
des conséquences éventuelles de ces
gestes ou deux enfants tout cas ce qu'on
montre qu'ils sont elles de la
responsabilité du politique en principe
est bien commençons
[Musique]
c'était une passard vous vous êtes
maître de conférences à sciences po
lille et chercheur au cnrs de miramont
vous enseignez à sciences po paris vous
avez tous deux dirigés la rédaction de
ce livre consacré à la satire et à la
liberté d'expression il s'intitule de
quoi se moque t-on il vient de paraître
aux éditions du cnrs avec des
contributions d'une vingtaine de
chercheurs et de spécialistes de la
question
la satire donc consiste à s'attaquer à
quelque chose ou à quelqu'un en s'en
moquant elle existe depuis toujours mais
elle ne va pas de soi c'est ça qui est
important car elle choque c'est son but
elle dépend donc de la liberté
d'expression qui existe à un moment et
dans un espace donné
est ce que c est ce que j'ai bien résumé
d'abord pour qu'on sache de quoi on
parle
oui tout à fait et en fait je pense que
l'esprit qui a guidé au départ
la publication de ce de ce recueil de
textes en fait sur la satire c'est
effectivement un contexte dans
lesquelles les débats médiatiques comme
vous l'avez d'ailleurs mentionné au
début de l'émission font volontiers
mention du fait qu'il est de plus en
plus difficile de se moquer de plus en
plus difficile de rire d'eux alors avec
derrière évidemment le spectre des
attentats mais pas seulement avec aussi
toutes sortes de polémiques qui implique
ce qu'on appelle généralement le
politiquement correct ou la canne seule
culture et qui implique donc de l'avis
de beaucoup de commentateurs en tout cas
dans les médias un rétrécissement
dramatique de l'espace du rire est donc
en fait une des intentions qui guidait
du coup je ce recueil c'était de prendre
du recul historiquement donc surtout
depuis le 19e siècle mais en réalité on
fait mention de choses bien antérieure
évidemment pour mentionner le type de
contrainte en fait qui pèsent sur
l'exercice de la satire qui évidemment
en tant qu il se moque un exercice qui
ne va pas de soi il faudra sans doute
décline d'ailleurs les cibles qui
historiquement sont les cibles
privilégiées des l'exercice satirique le
principe de la satire c'est que ça fait
mal hein on peut dire que est elle est
là pour ça si ça fait pas mal c'est pas
drôle et c'est pas de la satire
on peut dire ça comme ça c'est avec pas
ça oui c'est à dire dans la satire est
toujours un acte de dénonciation c'est à
dire que
la satire clairement peut-être à ce
qu'on pense parfois n'a pas forcément
pour but d'abord de faire rire c'est à
dire que le rire l'humour la caricature
sont au service d'une fin et une fin
politique de critique politique ou
sociale historiquement en tout cas et
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui on pense à la
satire de souza un mode plutôt de
l'humour comme vous l'avez dit mais qui
est trop culte cette dimension politique
qui a été sont consubstantielles au
genre satirique d'abord tel qu'il s'est
développé comme un genre littéraire mais
aussi comme une arme politique
la révolution française ou encore sous
la troisième république et c'est cet
aspect là souvent qui y qui choque
aujourd'hui à ces essais dès lors que
l'acsta tir devient une arme politique
et si le rire n'est plus la fin en soi
du de la satire on a l'impression que
c'est moi insupportable et d'ailleurs
c'est souvent quand les les satiristes
entre dans l'arène politique que ça pose
problème et qu'on l'avait vu avec
coluche pas et on se demande d'ailleurs
à chaque fois la différence qui peut y
avoir entre le satiriste et le polémiste
alors qu'est ce que c'est la différence
entre la 7e et la polémique se reprend
une distinction assez classique on peut
dire que la polémique en tant que tel
normalement elle considère que
l'adversaire et sur un plan quand même
de l'égalité relative on discute entre
entre égaux finalement le satiriste lui
se met dans une position un peu de
surplomb c'est à dire que il regarde
avec un peu d'ironie et donc et toujours
une forme de supériorité qui est présent
dans l'acte satirique qui pose
d'ailleurs justement le le le satiriste
comme quelqu'un qui peut paraître un peu
insensible aussi par rapport à ses
adversaires qu'il vise à dénoncer et
voir à baisser alors justement cette
insensibilité on voit bien qu'elle est
très présente dans la satire en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on lui reproche il y aurait
du mépris dans canton quand on se moque
il y aurait de l'injustice aussi c'est
quelque chose qui revient constamment on
trouve ça injuste et on trouve qu'à une
forme de destruction dans la satire est
ce que ça aussi c'est de tout temps
alors c'est en tout cas c'est en tout
cas des reproches qu'on a vu contre la
satire depuis longtemps et notamment
d'ailleurs au xviiie siècle quand on
commence effectivement à
réfléchir puisque la question de la
liberté d'expression même si l'express
l'expression n'existait pas en tant que
tel à l'époque mais la question de la
critique commencé à se poser un certain
nombre d'auteurs même avant le 18e
siècle des gens comme pierre bel est
ensuite les gens qui ont rédigé
l'article ça tire dans l'encyclopédie
prennent soin en fait de distinguer ce
qui serait la bonne critique
c'est-à-dire celles qui justement prend
là ni l'adversaire comme un égal à des
choses à proposer éventuellement orange
en renfort de sa critique et l'activité
de la satire qui est d'une part alors à
laquelle on fait un certain nombre de
critiques qui serait à la fois l'idée
part des intentions mauvaise c'est à
dire l'idée de rabaisser rabaissé son
adversaire le diaboliser et jusque même
jusqu'au point où elle a pu être
comparées à un homicide civile c'est à
dire on compare la satire une forme d'
homicide civile mais on lui reproche
également à cette satire de n'avoir
strictement rien à proposer c'est à dire
aussi un élément qui pourrait contribuer
à distinguer la satire de la polémique
parce que la polémique va toujours se
faire peut-être au nom d'une conception
de la vérité ou du bien alors que la
satire serait selon un terme qui leur
revient parfois dans le drap un exercice
gratuit et c'est à dire souvent cette
question de la gratuité de la satire qui
a été mis en cause dans un certain
nombre de procès y compris récemment
bon elle s'attire se fait toujours au
nom de quelque chose d'une morale qui
est censé être partagée par ceux qui ne
qui vous écoute pour que ce soit drôle
pour que l'on puisse se moquer de
quelque chose ou de quelqu'un il faut
d'abord qu'on soit d'accord sur un
certain nombre de normes
en effet c'est à dire que le satiriste
on peut dire que c'est un moraliste
outragé il ya une morale chez le
satiriste et de ce point de vue là il
peut la satire contrairement aussi
peut-être à ce pont quoi le renforcer
aussi des morale dominante ou des normes
sociales
donc c'est pas toujours non plus
simplement un contre-pouvoir c'est au
contraire rappeler aussi un ordre social
qui existe et qui est au nom duquel le
satiriste par là et dénonce finalement
des choses qu'ils estiment injuste ou
immoral alors on sait tous que ces
derniers temps la satire a donné lieu à
la controverse voire au scandale est-ce
que ça a toujours été le cas
disons que par rapport au paradoxe que
vous soulevez des débuts de l'émission
c'est à dire l'idée qu'on vous pourrez
plus rire de tout aujourd'hui
effectivement ça paraît paradoxal parce
qu'on n'a jamais pu rire de tout donc
toujours une des périodes dans lesquels
évidemment le satiriste était en
situation difficile et parfois
d'ailleurs cp au risque de
l'emprisonnement voire voire pire est
donc en fait pendant longtemps la satire
elle a surtout été en prise à la censure
et récents sur les gaz c'est à dire que
ce n'était pas possible de se moquer
ouvertement des autorités politiques
religieuses et évidemment par exemple si
on prend le cas de de l'ancien régime
sous l'ancien régime on ne peut pas se
moquer du roi 1 et donc ce qui est à la
limite tolérée s'est soudé fin ritualisé
alors par exemple on va avoir le bouffon
du roi le bouffon du roi c'est celui qui
est autorisé à se moquer du roi mais
sous une forme tellement outrancières ou
lui-même apparaît poux et donc il faut
finalement il faut être fou pour sauver
du roi mais françois 1er je crois
d'ailleurs goûtera pas beaucoup
justement les blagues de son de son
bouffon et donc de il va et un condamné
à mort et d'ailleurs il lui laissera
quand même le choix de deux de la peine
de mort et de eto'o qu'il dise
finalement moi je je je vais mourir de
je veux mourir de vieillesse est donc
finalement on s'est promis l'élu lui
laissera finalement disons à mourir de
vieillesse plutôt que de le conduire à
l'échafaud
et puis louis xiv lui va supprimer
complètement le le bouffon donc dans les
monarchies absolues il est même plus
possible à deux de rire ou même sous ces
voix qui sont des voies ritualisé on
peut être tribunicienne c'est à dire
qu'ils sont canalisés qui n'ont qu'un un
effet qui était un effet de renforcement
de l'ordre social c'est à dire que la
pop et ça et pas d'aidé forme de sept
pieds de deux satyres et s'attire
souterraine qui pouvaient exister qui
étaient là davantage réprimée
il ya plus récemment on se souvient que
honoré daumier célèbre caricaturiste va
faire de la prison je crois que c'est
sous le règne de louis-philippe donc ça
peut être très sévèrement condamnés mais
là on voit bien il s'agit de se moquer
des puissants s'agit de se moquer du
pouvoir que ce soit le pouvoir politique
le pouvoir religieux c'est toujours
toujours un problème en fait on sent
bien que la frontière elle est entre la
moquerie qui étaient admissibles et la
critique qui est intolérable et cette
frontière
elle est très flou non oui elle et elle
est très flou et d'ailleurs elle et elle
est restée longtemps puisque il n'y a
même pas besoin d'aller sous l'ancien
régime pouvoir des satiristes
éventuellement interdit ou censurés ou
emprisonnés puisque effectivement
charlie hebdo
non c'est quelque chose qui est connue
désormais mais charlie hebdo qui
aujourd'hui incarne en quelque sorte en
france
la survie de l'esprit satirique est tout
de même née d'une censure d'état puisque
l'on sait hara kiri qui titre en
ironisant effectivement sur la mort du
général de gaulle en 1969 et donc le
journal charlie donc en référence à
charles de gaulle n'est d'une censure
est effectivement très longtemps et
d'ailleurs pas seulement dans le domaine
de la satire les atteintes au corps
politique à la religion mais aussi à la
nation ont été incriminés et aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
peut continuer mais qui va en plus
semble-t-il rencontrer d un certain
nombre de mouvements de mouvements de
revendications qui ne se résume pas
évidemment aux pouvoirs politiques et
qui vont questionner justement la
légitimité de la satire et de la
critique au sycala qu'elle implique
quand on lit votre livre on voit bien
qu'il ya un espace de la satire et que
cet espace de la satire qui est variable
selon les lieux et les époques
il est délimité un par la loi
de la contrainte sociale et et 3 les
limites d'ordre éthique et politique
j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête un instant sur
chacun la loi est
évidemment la satire testent les limites
de la liberté d'expression et et du et
du droit d'opinion
ça c'est la loi la loi nous dit jusqu'où
on peut aller
c'est ça et en effet la satire que par
définition elle et transgressif donc à
la tendance à vouloir remettre en cause
ses limites qui sont ses limites légales
et historiquement elle a souvent
contribué d'ailleurs à développer on va
permettre de développer la liberté
d'expression et est justement en rusant
vous rappelez daumier par exemple on a
tout les tout l'épisode des pouvoirs
c'est à dire sous louis-philippe on va
se moquer du roi mais on ne représentant
pas directement le roi parce que
évidemment c'est est répréhensible et
donc on va représenter le roi sous forme
d'une poire en dix ans a finalement tout
le monde reconnaît dans la voir le roi
dont 4 ll rue j'ai donc y avait des
ruses avec la liberté d'expression tempe
et civiles aclu et c'était difficile de
s'opposer à la satire puisque justement
il ya des touches tout ce jeu là et
d'ailleurs
finalement la satire elle se renouvelle
et mais la censure aussi finalement se
renouvelle et 19e siècles on a une
figure qui s'appelle anna saisi là qui
est qu'il la femme ou au couteau et au
ciseau pardon qui représente la censure
cette censure et anastasie ça veut dire
la résurrection veut dire là à 100 sur
la censure légal elle se renouvelle tout
le temps pour autant les faits dans
notre société lieu 1881 on a une loi sur
la presse et créer libéral même si elle
a connu des modifications dans le
contexte récent et elle va permettre en
effet là d'un une diffusion beaucoup
plus large de de la satire surtout de la
satire au grand jour peut pas dire pour
autant qu'il reste pas des contraintes
légales parce que même dans le cadre de
la loi évidemment il ya des abus à la
liberté d'expression ont prévu et donc
injures la diffamation les discours de
haine et donc la satire and joue aussi
parfois un petit peu sur sur seul sur ce
jeu là et c'est ce qui est à la fois
intéressant dans la satire elle permet
de tester les vraiment les limites
véritable de la liberté d'expression
mais en même temps
elle se met souvent dans des situations
délicates paraît alors justement
toujours à la même question on peut plus
rire de rien avant pouvait rire de tout
en tout cas on vous pouvez rire de
beaucoup plus de choses il faut
considérer d'abord la loi
on l'a compris on y reviendra tout à
l'heure deuxièmement la contrainte
sociale et culturelle c'est à dire
qu'est ce que l'on trouve risible ou pas
ça ça change selon les pays
selon les époques aussi alors sur ce sur
ce point qu'est ce qu'il y a à dire
devenir ah non ça c'est effectivement ce
qui fait que la que c'était quelque
chose qui est assez assez connus
finalement c'est à dire que là les
normes du risible sont évidemment très
variables d'une époque à une autre et ça
paraît presque effectivement un truisme
à le dire et ça c'est des choses qu'on
voit par exemple lorsqu'on voit les
certains spectacles où certains films de
l'entre-deux-guerres par exemple qui est
je pense à des choses qui sont plus du
tout connus aujourd'hui comme la sq ont
appelé la saga des lévis était une série
de films à succès qui était tout à fait
antisémites et qui montrait une famille
de juifs sous un certain nombre de
traits tout à fait stéréotypé et qui à
l'époque effectivement ne choquait pas
particulièrement le public et que chacun
pouvait finalement trouvé drôle est allé
voir au même titre qu'un spectacle au
music hall donc en fait cet aspect là
pose problème pourquoi parce que la
critique satirique aujourd'hui
s'effectue dans un espace qui est
mondialisée est donc extrêmement facile
a diffusé par les réseaux sociaux et par
conséquent les des traits nationaux et
des manières nationale entre guillemets
de pratiquer la satire est l'humour
peuvent susciter parfois
l'incompréhension dans d'autres pays ou
dans d'autres cadres culturels de façon
sincère ou non et c'est évidemment ce
qui s'est passé entre autres pour les
questions de charlie hebdo où il
semblait en tout cas peut-être qu'il
faudrait revenir et approfondir sur ce
point que une certaine tradition
française de la satire entier religieuse
n'était pas tout simplement comprise en
fait en dehors de nos frontières
non seulement par des intégristes
religieux mais parce qu'ils seraient par
exemple une culture anglo saxonne plus
respectueuse des minorités
c'est pour ça que la satire en tout cas
dans le discours politique va toujours
de pair avec une sorte d' effort de
pédagogie
c'est à dire c'est comme ça que chez
nous on rit évidemment ces interventions
ne n'arrive pas à clore la question
c'est vraiment la différence entre
l'entretoit et le devant tout le monde
il ya des blagues qu'on peut faire entre
soi dans son cercle d'amis parce que on
en comprend les tenants et les
aboutissants et que l'on sait ce qu'il
ya derrière la tête de celui qui est en
train de faire cette blague on lui en
voudra pas y compris
la personne qui pourrait considérer que
les la cible la victime de cette blague
mais entre amis ça passe ça passerait
pas si le même la faisais la télé c'est
tout le problème des réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas très bien si
on est entre soi ou si on est à la télé
cherry pourtant dans on va les analyser
ça comme si on était à la télé c'est un
des problèmes justement d'entre eux soit
semble effectivement extrêmement
difficile pour une raison simple c'est
qu'en réalité dans une société et
notamment une société qui est marquée
par pas mal de différences ethniques
religieuses
on n'est jamais parfaitement entre soi
c'est à dire que même si on est entre
soi un repas on va être dans la vie
sociale confrontée à d'autres gens est
ce qu'on peut reprocher des associations
ou des groupes à l'exercice de la satire
c'est que finalement l'exercice de la
satire pouvaient être utilisés
effectivement pour renforcer une forme
d'entre eux soit dans un certain groupe
mais aussi jeter le site le discrédit
puisque justement la satire consiste à
se moquer et jeté le discrédit atteindre
à la réputation d'autres groupes
les bikers pas ça oui c'est ça c'est à
dire que en effet beaucoup des
polémiques ou des controverses ou des
scandales même qui apparaissent
aujourd'hui et même ce discours sur un
peu plus rire de tout vient sans doute
que des choses qui étaient autrefois
réservées à des as
ddd groupe sous un mode informel
aujourd'hui son exposé publiquement et
par exemple on l'a dit pour charlie
hebdo c'est c'est bien car c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui de d'emblée les unes se
retrouve à la fois présente sur sur des
réseaux sociaux
devant un public et même au niveau
mondial qui ne sont pas des par le
public habituel qui était celui de
charlie hebdo historiquement ou ou de
hara kiri avant et donc évidemment ça
crée des malentendus et du coup il ne
reste plus dans la satire que l'aspect
qui n'est plus l'aspect risi parce que
ce risible et n'est pas forcément
compris dès lors qu'on en sort du groupe
parce que le rire est toujours le
d'un groupe mais il reste que la
dénonciation ou l'agressivité est
évidemment ressenti quand du mépris mais
de venir à bout faisait allusion à ses
films de l'entre-deux-guerres
qu'aujourd'hui on considérerait comme
antisémite et vous disiez à l'époque ça
ne choquait personne
moi je vois que ça a choqué des tas de
gens renoncent à choquer les juifs
premièrement mais aussi tous les anti
antisémite qui trouvait ça très choquant
de même que les caricatures qu'on
pouvait voir dans la presse
simplement la loi était différente la
loi laissait s'exprimer ce type de
satire
aujourd'hui elle arrête laisserait plus
et et puis surtout aujourd'hui on
l'éthique a changé c'est à dire que l
est à l'époque les antisémites avaient
le droit de se moquer des juifs
aujourd'hui les tic veut que même les
antisémites n'ai plus le droit de se
moquer des juifs
on ne veut plus entendre et ça oui mais
je pense que vous avez raison quand je
dis nous choquer personne c'est-à-dire
n'était pas l'objet d'un traitement d'un
traitement légal en tout cas collectif
et étatiques les en fait ce qui s'est
passé entre les deux c'est quand même
assez simple c'est celle inventée la
seconde guerre mondiale et je pense que
effectivement une partie très importante
de notre législation sur la liberté
d'expression est en quelque sorte
hanté par justement cette période de
l'entre-deux-guerres ou en fait tu
n'existais pas de restriction de la
liberté d'expression de ce qu'on appelle
en tout cas les discours de haine il
existe évidemment des limitations de la
liberté d'expression pour préserver les
bonnes moeurs ou là ou éventuellement la
morale publique
mais il n'existait pas effectivement
d'incrimination pour l'incitation à la
haine raciale pour les injures ça ce
sont des choses qui sont arrivées
largement après la seconde guerre
mondiale toute cette législation est
inspiré par le fait qu'en réalité cette
liberté d'expression excessive qui
avaient libre cours en tout cas dans les
sociétés européennes pas seulement en
france mais aussi en allemagne en
autriche dans l'entre-deux-guerres a
contribué largement à été en quelque
sorte cause ou en tout cas adjuvant de
l'extermination et des génocides qui ont
eu lieu par la suite et donc c'est une
raison pour laquelle la la plupart des
sociétés européennes en fait la totalité
des sociétés européennes ce sont deux
tde législation à partir des années 60
70 contre ce qu'on appelle les discours
de haine et c'est justement en fait sur
ses lois que s'inscrivent la plupart des
polémiques récentes autour de la satire
pourquoi parce que comme on l'a dit tout
à l'heure à la satire presque par sa
fonction à vocation à être agressif y
compris de la loi alors quand la loi
consiste à protéger la morale et le chef
de l'état la satire va être presque
naturellement portés dialectiquement
presque à s'attaquer à ces institutions
là lorsque la loi protège justement par
référence en tout cas aux crimes passés
des groupes d'individus définis par leur
race leur ethnie leur religion la
question c'est est-ce que la satire ne
va pas presque par fonction est ramenée
à s'attaquer à ces lois et à ces groupes
et c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles en fait l'exercice de la
satire est si difficile aujourd'hui
effectivement ce qui change on le voit
bien à partir après la seconde guerre
mondiale et puis surtout dans les années
60 70
c'est tout à coup on va trouver des
limites d'ordre éthique et politique est
la satire des instants où elles
s'exercent vis-à-vis des plus faibles
des minoritaires ou des persécutés et là
ça devient problématique
on va tout à coup à la fois parce que
les satiristes vont être tentés d'y
aller quand même
et d'ailleurs il ne s'en prive pas tant
qu'il n'y ait tant qu'on ne les en
empêche pas il
il se moque allègrement des femmes des
noirs des arabes des juifs avant la
guerre après ils font plus attention
effectivement parce qu'ils savent
jusqu'où cela peut aller ensuite mais
ils vont continuer avec énormément de
minorités et c'est finalement les
minorités qui vont demander à un moment
que ça c'est ce qu'on les traite comme
on a traité avec plus d'égards
parce que sinon ça peut dégénérer je
propose de faire une pause
on se retrouve juste après et on
continue
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec cédric pas
s'arrêter de miramont à propos de leurs
livres de quoi se moque t-on qui vient
de paraître aux éditions du cnrs
on a bien vu on le voit très bien de
votre livre comment à un moment la
liberté d'expression est limitée parce
qu'on ne veut pas que les la satire
s'attaque au pouvoir s'attaquent ni nier
au pouvoir politique ni au pouvoir
religieux
et puis ensuite on va le commencé à
vouloir protéger alors on ne protège
plus le pouvoir il yal outrage au chef
de l'état
mais finalement tout ce qui relève de la
protection de la jeunesse d outrage aux
bonnes moeurs tout ça va être au fur et
à mesure détruits par les satiristes eux
mêmes dans les années 60 70
on voit bien tout ça disparaît et laminé
au fur et à mesure jusqu'à loutre âge au
chef de l'état qui va disparaître si on
peut se moquer du chef de l'état
d'ailleurs le général de gaulle on peut
s'en moquer pourquoi est ce que j'avais
hara kiri et censuré c'est parce qu'il
vient de mourir
et là on demande un minimum de respect
au fond mais avant ça on pouvait se
moquer du général de gaulle bien entendu
et au fossé bascule parce que ce sont
tout à coup les minorités les faibles
qui ne veulent plus qu'on se moque d'eux
faut dire ils en ont vu des vertes et
des pas mûres il faut quand même voir ce
que ça a été ça n'a pas été drôle
toujours pour eux ah oui tout à fait en
fait quand on d'ailleurs quand on pointe
ce phénomène effectivement ce n'est pas
du tout en tout cas dans l'esprit du
livre
l'idée n'est absolument pas justement
d'entrer dans le discours selon lequel
l'ami la liberté d'expression serait
l'objet de la tyrannie des minorités
évidemment il ya une pluralité de points
de vue dans le livre sur ce point là
mais en tout cas l'idée générale du
livre était plutôt d'aller dans le sens
il me semble inverse c'est à dire de
montrer effectivement un déplacement des
des enjeux est effectivement là dans la
mesure où là où la loi a changé pour
effectivement devenir plus protectrice
les questions les en tout cas les enjeux
sur la limitation de la liberté
d'expression se sont focalisés de plus
en plus sur la question des stéréotypes
ou des caricatures
or justement quels sont les camps en
quelque sorte les instruments de la
satire c'est justement le jeu sur les
stéréotypes et les caricatures sauf que
le problème c'est qu'à partir du moment
vous entretenez des stéréotypes et des
caractè tueur sur des groupes qu'ils
s'agissent de la liste quelque part des
victimes ou des considérait victime
habituelle ce que ce soit je sais pas
moi les minorités de genre où les
minorités raciales
évidemment vous allez non pas heurter
des sensibilités seulement contrairement
à ce qu'on dit souvent que vous allez
pas seulement offensés mais vous allez
être accusés de contribuer à des
systèmes de domination qui existe déjà
si bien qu'en fait l'exercice de la ciat
tir du mois en france en tout cas aider
hermes est désormais parfois accusés de
faire le jeu du pouvoir et c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle pour le dire un
peu brutalement aussi la liberté
d'expression depuis deux ou trois
décennies est une valeur en tout cas
dans l'espace public est devenu très
marqué mes yeux en tout cas à droite ce
qui n'a évidemment pas toujours été le
cas dans l'histoire et c'est là en fait
que surgisse tous les problèmes parce
que là c'est une situation qui est assez
nouvelle en réalité est effectivement
dans les années 60 70 c'était plutôt la
gauche qui voulait gagner en liberté
d'expression aussi bien charlie hebdo
que le l'hebdomadaire pilote qui est un
hebdomadaire de bande dessinée que
coluche que tout le monde et est
qu'aujourd'hui on dirait ce serait
plutôt les gens de gauche qui sont
accusés de vouloir limiter la liberté
d'expression parce qu'il voudrait
protéger effectivement les minorités les
minorités de genre ou
et en fait c'est là dessus que c'est que
c'est beaucoup exercé la satire sur le
genre sur l'orientation sexuelle sur
l'identité de genre sur le handicap même
on se souvient de patrick timsit accusé
par une association de défense de
personnes handicapées donc on voit bien
que tout se passe de la même façon un
sinon on peut dire c'est dans une
passoire
oui sachant que justement quand même la
loi en tout cas en france reconnaît un
statut particulier aux humoristes
si on revient juste sur les questions
légales et donc généralement elle permet
une forme d'outrance quand même plus
plus important en prenant en compte
justement le fait que chacun s'exprime
un peu comme un clown à condition encore
une fois que le satiriste reste dans son
rôle de de satiriste les nôtres passe
pas lui-même sa qualité en quelque sorte
d'humoriste et puis par ailleurs ce
qu'on voit alors effectivement là on
sort parfois du registre en prenant
satirique au sens politique du terme
mais ces questions là qui ont trait à
tous qui est le genre les identités de
groupe sont aussi aujourd'hui quand même
un élément très important de justement
de l'humour un du stand-up où justement
on voit que iliad est une nouvelle
génération d'humoristes qui s'amusent à
déconstruire aussi ça est justement à
jouer sur sur le registre du discours on
ne peut plus rien dire
un peu comme faisait des proches en
disant au départ en entrant dans le
spectacle demandant est ce que est ce
qui est des juifs dans la salle un
parfum ont dit qu'ils ne pourrez plus
dire l'or étaient à plat d'humoristes
aujourd'hui qui joue sur ce même type de
rhétorique en réalité et fiction il a
bien plus qu'avant et on oublie toujours
quand on cite ce fameux sketch de
desproges de préciser qu'il n'avait
jamais été diffusé à la télévision à
l'époque la à cette époque parce qu'on
avait peur que ça choque justement et
que aujourd'hui on le re diffusons leur
rediffuse mais à l'époque il en était
pas question
elle des gens évidemment le complètement
oublié
et on voit bien que il ya un autre
problème aujourd'hui c'est que très
souvent ce sont des associations qui
portent plainte et dès l'instant où une
association porte plainte contre un
humoriste l'état s'associe à
l'association
mais au fond ce ne sont pas ou se sont
très rarement les victimes celles ou
ceux qui auraient pu se reconnaître dans
la satire conte et être en train de leur
infliger et éventuellement en souffrir
non eux ne se manifeste pas parfois ils
s'indignent sur les réseaux sociaux mais
sont pas eux qui portent plainte quand
on porte plainte c'est ça et puis
justement ce qui est intéressant par
rapport à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est que on a l'impression
aujourd'hui du côté politique
tout du moins il ya une grande
acceptation de la satire politique c'est
à dire que je pense que ces terres en 87
elle est encore charles pasqua qui avait
essayé justement de se poser à des
formes de caricature est révolue même
mettre en place une sorte de musée de
l'horreur et finalement ça s'est
retourné contre lui parce que justement
on avait voulu on y avait vu une sorte
de reprise en main un peu autoritaire et
la presse de l'époque finalement avait
très mal très mal à accepter cette
logique de retour d'un à une volonté de
censure et donc au niveau aujourd'hui
d'aider des acteurs politiques la
plupart d'ailleurs eux mêmes s'ils ne
prennent pas forcément plaisir à se voir
caricaturé
généralement il accepte assez assez bien
la caricature et les bandes ont
d'ailleurs cherché plein de d'acteurs
politiques de dire qu'ils apprécient
même leur propre leur propre caricature
et et je pense que l'assemblée nationale
avait organisé il ya quelques années
d'ailleurs aussi une exposition de la
caricature donc on voit bien ce
changement là de manière importante au
niveau politique par contre en effet ce
qui est
ce qui est des plaies le déplacement se
fait par le fait qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui
éventuellement vont attaquer en justice
ce sont plutôt éventuellement des
associations avaient vu à un moment
donné avec une là aussi une caricature
de nadine morano justement qui avait été
représentée en fille trisomique de
charles de gaulle parlera par charlie
hebdo et c'était une association de
personnes handicapées qui avait
en tout cas de familles de personnes
handicapées qui avait porté plainte même
si t'es pas la principale association
est pas nadine morano elle même et donc
et parfois ça se joue plutôt sur sur ce
sur ce jeu là en fait on voit bien là qu
on est en plein dans l'espace de la
satire tel que vous le définissez dans
votre livre elle savoir donc on l'a dit
la loi mais aussi ensuite l'acceptation
sociale les contraintes culturelles et
sociales qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui est
risible et qu'est ce qui ne l'est pas et
puis l'éthique et la politique
ensuite qui vont faire qu'il va s'en
mêler d'une manière ou d'une autre et
qui vont nous dire à la fin est ce que
c'est drôle ou pas drôle telle blague de
tels humoristes ou de pagnes me risque
d'ailleurs il ya eu le fameux mur des
cons du syndicat de la magistrature
là tout à coup ça n'était plus des
humoristes donc ce qu avait le droit de
faire le bébête show ou où les guignols
de l'info le syndicat de la magistrature
n'avez pas le droit de faire parce que
c'était eux qui ensuite allé d'où nous
juger et et juger les hommes politiques
et donc le mur des cons c'était
inacceptable on voit bien que là on est
où on n'est pas dans l'espace autorisé
de la satire
oui et d'ailleurs un des traits assez
assez remarquable sens de la satire
c'est que effectivement il ya des il ya
des procès on pourrait en citer
quelques-uns eux à commencer évidemment
par le procès contre charlie hebdo mais
qui avait d'ailleurs été gagné par le
journal en 2007 je crois mais en fait la
plupart des polémiques en fait
concernant la satire ne se déroule pas
forcément dans les tribunaux pour une
raison à mon avis assez simple c'est que
les questions de satire ne sont pas
facilement facile à résoudre par la loi
c'est à dire que justement on est dans
des dans des affaires de représentation
de stéréotypes d'appréciation
extrêmement subtile et différencié de
rapport de force entre les groupes de
manière de se percevoir qui sont pas
faciles à résoudre par le droit aussi
facilement que pourrait l'être par
exemple une injure ou une menace de mort
qui serait caractérisée est d'ailleurs
une des raisons peut-être pour lesquels
les affaires de satire son si grand
bruit c'est justement
probablement parce que le droit a
énormément de mal à s'en emparer et ça
que c'est quelque chose qu'on voit par
exemple aux états unis
où il ya puisque les états unis seront
sans cesse site est à la fois comme une
sorte d'enfer de la liberté d'expression
puisqu'il y aurait plein de groupes sur
les campus qui empêcherait de s'exprimer
et en même temps un paradis de la
liberté d'expression puisque en principe
il n'y a aucune limitation de la liberté
d'expression aux états unis en tout cas
pour les discours de haine
et justement il me semble que s'ils
avaient polémique et si des polémiques
peuvent exercer arrivé que ce soit par
des pétitions par des manifestations sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est pour critiquer
tel dessin on en a eu des exemples
encore récemment c'est que ce sont
justement aussi des affaires qu'on ne
qu'on n'arrive pas à judiciariser et qui
sont justement traité sur le sur le mode
politique et morale plus que sur le
terrain judiciaire
alors aujourd'hui ce qu'est ce qui est
très différent c'est que tel sketch tel
satire va être vécue ou en tout cas
c'est ce qui est dit comme une blessure
personnelle mais il y a des gens qui
vont dire que c'est une blessure
personnelle pour les autres c'est pas
forcément ceux qui sont censés être
blessé qui se manifestent c'est quelque
chose de très important en fait très
souvent les gens qui s'indignent de
telle blague de de telles scènes de
films de tels jeux de mots de peu
importe le registre de la fête de la
satire que ceux qui sont indignes le
plus fort ne ce ne sont pas ceux qui
sont blessés ou qui sont censés être
blessé personnellement c'est
véritablement une caractéristique de
notre époque de semble-t-il
oui mais en même temps on pourrait enfin
vous avez raison d'une certaine manière
mais on pourrait dire aussi que beaucoup
de défenseurs de la cause ouvrière au
19e siècle était aussi de bons bourgeois
c'est à dire que l'on peut aussi ne pas
être dans une dans une situation est là
elle a ressenti je pense que cela dit je
pense que vous avez vous avez raison
mais il faut aussi voir que peut-être
qu'on a tort de le placer sous l'angle
de la blessure personnelle où justement
de là comment dire de l'atteinte
psychologique c'est à dire que ce qu'on
reproche parfois à des sketches où
effectivement à des dessins c'est
effectivement d'une certaine manière de
blessés ce qu'il ait ressenti comme tel
et donc on va avoir toute cette
rhétorique de la blessure de l'oph ans
mais derrière c'est aussi des moyens
pour des associations et des partis
politiques de moby
10 et autour d'un certain nombre de
causes d'ailleurs de façon plus ou moins
avec plus ou moins de bonne foi puisque
on a bien vu effectivement que par
exemple l'histoire des caricatures de
charlie hebdo
des manifestations avaient été
organisées dans des pays à majorité
musulmane par des gens qui n'avaient
absolument jamais vu les caricatures
mais ça reste en fait des moyens
effectivement de créer il me semble des
rapports des rapports de forces
politiques qui dépassent la question
effectivement delà de la blessure
individuelles qui qui est presque de
toute façon impossible a constaté ou à
mesurer d'ailleurs de la même façon ce
droit d'offenser qui est revendiqué
aujourd'hui en tout cas officiellement
officiellement on dit on a le droit de
penser c'est même une caractéristique
française comme si les autres n'avaient
jamais pratiqué la satire comme si c'est
de nous était réservé m'enfin ça passe
on mais on voit bien que ce droit
d'offenser qui est consubstantiel on va
dire à la république
il fut un temps où la limite est en
fonction d'une norme générale la
protection de la jeunesse ou de
l'enfance les bonnes moeurs
tout ce qui était considéré comme un
outrage aux bonnes moeurs pouvait être
censuré et c'étaient les bonnes moeurs
parce que les bonnes moeurs de qui
scella les moeurs des honnêtes gens
voilà les années de gens c'était la
norme on pourrait dire que il y avait la
dation ou quoi que ça ait beaucoup
baissé depuis la guerre de 14 ou la
république ou chef de l'état qui avait
une dignité particulière qui nous
fallait respecter
aujourd'hui ça a changé tout ça a plus
ou moins volé en éclats du fait des
satiristes d'ailleurs la plupart du
temps des années 60 70
à chaque fois ils gagnent du terrain et
aujourd'hui c'est la sensibilité de
chacun qu'on met en avant et
particulièrement les victimes
aujourd'hui le nouveau sacre est ce plus
la jeunesse c'est plus l'enfance et plus
les bonnes moeurs et plus les années de
gens ce sont les victimes les victimes
celles qui ont déjà été victimes ou
celles qui pourraient demain devenir
victimes se sont elles au fond que l'on
protège
oui alors d'une certaine manière parce
que vous avez raison en fait le droit
sur la liberté d'expression
et passer à certains égards de la
défense de notions d'identité qui sont
général la morale l'état civil
enfin le bleu dont la paix civile et
tous à la protection éventuellement
d'individus et de groupes contre un
certain nombre de de préjudice et
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être une évolution
dont alors là à mon sens en tout cas on
doit peut-être se féliciter c'est à dire
qu'on peut considérer que après tout
personne n'est tout à fait d'accord sur
la définition des bonnes moeurs ou de la
morale publique et donc il n'est pas
forcément du ressort de l'état de la
protéger en revanche on voit bien les
raisons pour lesquelles il faut
éventuellement protéger des individus
contre des incitations à la violence et
à la et à la discrimination la question
que vous posez derrière tout ça c'est en
fait la définition il me semble
justement des frontières de cette
offense c'est à dire la sensibilité et
c'est quelque chose dont on a parlé vite
avant ne peut en fait pas servir de
critère puisque la sensibilité bien
entendu est variable des gens sont
sensibles au blasphème d'autres y sont
tout à fait insensible et donc non pas
plusieurs auteurs ont tenté de poser des
limites je pense par exemple à quelqu'un
comme un philosophe comme ruwen ogien
que coderre vous aviez lu n'a guère eu
un vide et qui posait les critères oui
tout à fait et qui lui par exemple
distinguer les offenser les préjudices
lui qui défendent la liberté
d'expression disait qu'on avait
parfaitement le droit de d'offenser
c'est-à-dire d'attaqué des choses
général des croyances et des convictions
mais qu'on ne pouvait pas atteindre à
atteindre des personnes en incitant à la
violence contre elle et travaillez
souvent primés ou simplement de leur
porter préjudice
c'est à dire que deux de se moquer d'eux
on a le droit de penser les croyances de
quelqu'un on a le droit de penser sa
morale mais on n'a pas le droit de lui
porter préjudice c'est à dire de lui
faire du mal de l'empêcher d'entrer de
l'empêcher de travailler de l'empêcher
de vivre ici ou là mais on n'a le droit
de s'en moquer c'était ça lui
si je
je veux pas plus lui je crois que c'est
la limite qu'il portait en fait mais il
n'est pas le seul d'ailleurs les autres
le font en dix ans et donc et c'est pour
ça sauf ans enfin sauf ans elle aussi du
fait que ce soit des associations qui
point qu'ils puissent se porter partie
civile
vis-à-vis d'une chance que n'ont pas
forcément ressenti ce qu'ils sont censés
être offensés oui bien sûr mais en fait
justement dans les procès la question de
l'offensé est une chose mais ce que
c'est des associations reprochent en
général aux caricatures et dessins c'est
justement leur porter préjudice
c'est à dire de considérer non pas
qu'ils sont seulement offensés mais de
dire qu'il s'agit là d'une incitation à
la haine d'une injure ou diffamation
portant sur des groupes c'est à dire
qu'en fait l'argumentation se fait
toujours sur le mode du préjudice et il
me semble qu en fait une des tâches de
là peut-être de la philosophie en plus
qu'à et aussi du droit et de l'encens
des disciplines c'est de s'interroger
assez assez rigoureusement sur ce que
signifie un préjudice mais en tout cas
il me semble qu'on peut partir de tête
distinction type offensé préjudice pour
réfléchir justement aux frontières
éthique éventuellement juridique
justement de l'exercie de la satire on
voit bien à la fin de votre livre
d'ailleurs que au fond on est dans un
nouvel esprit de censure depuis quelques
années dans un pays comme comme le nôtre
c'est l'esprit de censure qui a changé
il est toujours vertueux parce que la
censure est toujours vertueuse mais il
est en train de devenir sans limite au
fond puisque on est tous d'accord vous
l'êtes un peu je le suis un peu on l'est
tous pour dire que effectivement il ya
des trucs bas ce serait bien d'arrêter
là où que ça peut faire mal ou
qu'effectivement ça vient en renfort des
véritable discrimination des véritables
discours de m
au fond on est tous parties prenantes
pour interdire pour censurer pour
demander aux gens de ne pas mettre
d'huile sur le feu
etc etc tout ça va à l'encontre
évidemment de la satire et de la liberté
d'expression mais au fond ce ne sont
plus des valeurs aussi aussi sacré
qu'elle l'était au fond les les la
sensibilité de chacun est en train de
devenir le nouveau sacré la difficulté
c'est que la liberté d'expression en
effet par par définition s'applique
aussi à ce qu'on aime pas donc
en effet il faut faut accepter de
d'entendre ou de lire des choses qui
nous choque car les individuellement
c'est ce que fait d'ailleurs le droit
après comme comme le disait denis en
effet il ya des choses aussi qu'ils
peuvent être malgré tout on peut juger
qu'elles sont intolérables et et la
satire n'est pas non plus par essence
bonne hein c'est à dire qu'il ya aussi
une toute une tradition satirique qui a
pu être justement porteuse
elle avait rappelé toute la leur de
discours de haine qui a pu même parfois
légitimes mais après les préjudices et
est donc préparé préparer au pire et
c'est donc en ce sens que aujourd'hui on
voit bien comment cet espace de la
satire il est il est confronté à cette
difficulté dans un espace démocratique
la satire and change un peu drôle c'est
à dire que historiquement quand elle
était face à une censure officielle
c'était c'était difficile d'un port et
satiriste mais disons que l'ailé les
satiristes il participait à la liberté
d'expression il participé à la
contestation de l'ordre social dominant
dans un espace démocratique 5 et peu
plus un petit peu plus compliqué parce
que justement parfois la satire elle
peut paradoxalement participé aussi à
reproduire des préjugés et des
stéréotypes et on sait pas toujours
depuis on se moquerait et donc ces deux
là toute l'ambiguïté il ya une
contribution dans le livre par exemple
sur sur pénélope fillion et sur la
sphère qui ya entouré donc l'élection
présidentielle est bon là la ps2 de
l'auteur cessé de montrer quand même que
m'a parfois on s'apprête peut-être moins
sont à françois fillon que peut-être à
pénélope est donc réel
c'est là qu'il ya des difficultés et
finalement la satire elle peut aussi
contribuer à développer des aspects un
peu sexiste
même sans le vouloir donc aux fonds non
seulement on est dans un nouvel esprit
de censure qui les vertueux il pourrait
bien être sans limites mais en plus et
c'est quand même fondamental on a
privatisé la censure autrefois la
censure était le le monopole on va dire
de la puissance publique
aujourd'hui tout le monde peut être
censeurs tout le monde peut attaquer
tout le monde ça veut pas dire qu'on
gagne d'ailleurs très souvent on a
tendance à confondre ceux qui demandent
l'interdiction ceux qui s'indignent et
des censeurs très souvent on s'indigne
et on ne demande aucune interdiction est
d'ailleurs on n'a aucune chance d'en
obtenir non plus mais on attend ça tout
à tout confondre tout simplement parce
que la censure a été privatisée à partir
du nouveau code pénal dans les années 90
on sait qu'il n'ya plus de censure mais
que tout le monde a le droit de demander
l'ascension de n'importe quoi c'est
surtout qu'on entend plus peut-être
aussi simplement
justement comme voulu rappeler avec les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui chacun peut
s'indigner et toujours eu des gens
indignez vous le rappeler dans les
années 30
évidemment on pouvait s'aligner aussi
contrôler les caricatures antisémites
après c'est une question de rapport de
force et une capacité à se faire
entendre par des groupes ou par des des
porte parole donc ce qui est peut-être
nouveau c'est ça aujourd'hui 1 c'est
aussi l'importance qu'on donne aux
réseaux sociaux est évidemment à des
plâtres mais qui n'aboutissent pas
toujours parce que en réalité comme la
jurisprudence en france elle est quand
même relativement libérale il ya au fond
beaucoup moins deux condamnations qu'on
imagine
mais il ya aussi le pouvoir peut
parfaitement enfin le pouvoir dans une
entreprise n'importe où peut choisir
peut décider d'expulser quelqu'un
une manière de le condamner même si la
loi elle ne le condamne pas on l'a vu et
c est ça arrive constamment et là on
voit bien qu'on est dans le nouvel
espace de la satire et que ce nouvel
espace de la satire il est délimité
alors est-ce qu'il est plus réduit
aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'était il ya ya 30
ou 40 ans il semblerait que oui quand on
lit votre livre oui évidemment très très
difficile à mesurer
et puis comme vous l'a rappelé à juste
titre en fait là là le fait de ceux de
prétendre sans cesse être censuré ne
renvoie pas forcément à une réalité mais
il est toujours très avantageuse d'un
point de vue rhétorique de se présenter
comme censure et a fortiori qu'on
voulait pas réellement c'est à dire que
se prétendre censure et c'est finalement
une manière aussi d'échapper à la
discussion et à la critique et vous avez
tout à fait raison je pense qu'en fait
aujourd'hui les frontières de la liberté
d'expression sont largement autant
dessiné par la loi et par les juges que
par des mécanismes privé qui échappent
en fait très largement à la
compréhension des gens et des
utilisateurs notamment les plateformes
puisqu'on commence aujourd'hui à
réfléchir et analyser à la façon dont
des plateformes effectivement réguler
leur contenu selon des normes qui sont
parfois un petit peu opaque et surtout
des mécanismes qui sont un petit peu
opaque et donc là on va forcément voir
arriver ce sera intéressant à constater
des manières de contourner tout ça est
la question ce sera plus forcément
comment contourner la loi ou comme on
contourne un juge mais comment
contourner un algorithme et on peut se
demander à quoi ça va ressembler à
propos des gens qui disent qu'ils ont
été censurés qu'elles ne sont pas je me
suis à guy bedos qui a toujours dit
qu'il avait été censurée sous le la
présidence de valéry giscard d'estaing
qu'il était interdit de télé et à
georges la vie tel est lé vision et
jeudis vous savez si vous aviez été en
censuré je vous aurais jamais vu puisque
moi j'étais petit sou mais la giscard
d'estaing rouge a l'impression vous
étiez là tout le temps et il dit non non
non j'ai été censuré la fois d'après je
lui ai sorti tous les extraits
d'émissions ils avaient tous fait
absolument toutes les émissions pendant
la présidence de valéry giscard
d'estaing
mais même en voyant ça j'ai dit alors
oui vous pourrez plus dire vous a été
censurée liban heureusement qu'il y
avait des gens qui résistait
voilà c'est à dire que quoi qu'il arrive
de stress au celui qui vous dit il a été
censuré
il continuera de penser qu'il a aidé les
ostensions et un dernier mot
c'est ait pas ça oui la censure c'est
c'est disons le vraiment le le compagnon
le privilégié de la satire lorsque la
satire a toujours besoin d'un ennemi
dont elle a toujours besoin de la santé
sur elle n'existe que parce qu'elle
accueille la censure
aujourd'hui c'est vrai il faudrait pas
croire que la satire a disparu au
contraire et la spirale est présent même
dans des registres au cinématographique
dans dans des séries les simpson ça il
ya menace attire aussi de d'angora fils
et de la satire on classe attirer les
présente de manière très mais très forte
mais elle a parfois perdu un petit peu
souvent son contenu politique et pour
reprendre une expression qui dit que
dans l'ouvragé on peut avoir parfois
l'impression que ça tire partout il
référence nulle part merci tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cette émission de
quoi se moque t-on c'est le titre de ce
livre qui vient de paraître aux éditions
du cnrs merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]